the families have been in and out of
courtrooms for seven years I missed my
mom internally and deeply um my brother
as well all of them on January 3rd 2017
Corporal Lionel Desmond legally bought a
semi-automatic rifle a few hours later
he shot and killed his wife Shaina their
10-year-old daughter Aaliyah and his
mother Brenda he then fatally shot
himself the tragic end to the rifleman's
battle against PTSD after serving two t
in Afghanistan the inquiry heard how
Desmond and his health care providers
struggled to access his military health
records and how he faced delays in
trying to get care through both Veterans
Affairs Canada and provincial Health
Services leading to what the judge
called quote a large crack in
Psychotherapy through which Corporal
Desmond fell this has been an arduous
and emotional process judge Paul
scoville's recommendations include
making sure Ottawa provides a case
manager to Veterans as they transition
out of service and that the Nova Scotia
government improved the transfer of
health records by working with other
provinces and federal agencies along
with ensuring Frontline workers get
upto-date information on intimate
partner violence other recommendations
focus on better background checks and
reassessments for firearms licenses
nothing here relates to assisting the
bordon family for the tragedy that took
place but for Shaya Desmond's family the
report is a disappointment they still
live in the home where the killings
happened and say Veterans Affairs has
ignored their pleas for help the first
way to begin to help the families heal
is to help the family with relocating
the federal Minister only saying overall
changes have been made we certainly want
to move forward in in improving any
services that we can in order to make
life better for our veterans and also
their family members the inquiry
recommends a special committee to track
progress on the recommendations so
they're not lost the judge said to the
passage of time after the families have
spent so long waiting Heidi pic Global
News Port hawksbury Nova Scotia